I fell in love with film when I was a
when I was 13 years old and I wanted to
become a director I grew up in
Switzerland and people felt that it was
like becoming an astronaut and going to
the moon but I pursued that dream I went
to film school actually that was a major
thing for me to be accepted at UCLA it
was one of the premiere film schools in
America and I went there I planned to be
there for four years and get a BA
however that was not enough so I decided
to go to graduate school and the idea
was to have made some films and be a
director however when I came back to
Switzerland there wasn't really any any
work in film so I decided to go back to
the United States extend my education
but not to pursue directing but editing
which was something I fell in love with
while I was doing my my films at a film
school I really discovered the power of
editing while doing documentaries and
short films
I think if if you want to become an
editor at least you've experienced some
form of passion for film I think that's
key to have that passion because you're
gonna be working many hours but besides
that you have to have an imaginative
mind you like to do things with your
hands and trying to solve problems you
have to use your imagination so if you
have all those qualities then you should
become an editor or at least pursue that
interest but I think the key to all that
is simply have a love and passion for it
when I was starting
an assistant the best at what advice I
got was from very early on from Claire
Simpson who was editing Wall Street at
the time and she also had worked with
one of the great editors she was
assisting Dede Allen so she told me the
story that the island told her she's
kind of like the godmother of editors
cut Bonnie and Clyde and you know a lot
of other great pictures because the the
mother of modern and she heard what
Beebe Island told Claire Simpson and
Claire Simpson told me is like
everything is about rhythm and that
stayed with me as a very good advice it
is rhythm it moves you it it also
reflects the rhythm of your heart in
terms of emotion so rhythm is very
important and the other advice that I
think about is what Oliver said they
said that we no matter what you do don't
be boring so that's about it